Racing to save the wounded on the
streets of Strasbourg the city's
world-famous Christmas market now the
site of a deadly mass shooting a gunman
opened fire on revelers here Tuesday
night before fleeing the scene witnesses
spoke of panic and terrified people as
the shots rang out I saw a lot of people
running scared crying kids and all then
I said I think this must be very very
serious and then when I saw people
crying and the crowd leaving they said
it was a shooting right next door so I
ran away I went to hide in a restaurant
French president Emanuela McColl held an
emergency meeting with cabinet officials
at the presidential palace afterwards
he tweeted out his condolences saying
the whole nation stands in solidarity
with Strasbourg our victims and their
families French authorities raised the
terror alert to the highest possible
level as they searched for the 29 year
old shooting suspect unknown criminal
the man is known for civil law offenses
for which he was already condemned in
France and in Germany the government has
decided to switch to his state of
emergency and reinforced controls at
border crossings we are also stepping up
security at all of the christmas markets
around france to avoid similar events
from happening france has borne the
brunt of some of Europe's worst terror
attacks in recent years now the country
again finds itself in the crosshairs and
EWS max Hoffman is on the scene he joins
us now max we understand that there has
been a police operation underway this
morning in downtown Strasbourg what more
have you been seeing there
I am in downtown Strasburg behind me use
we're very close to where all of this
happened last night so where the
shooting took place you see still see
the Christmas decoration which is part
of the official Christmas market we are
not aware of a police operation that
took place if it took place it's not a
very big one as far as we know only one
media outlet reported it so far with one
source so we're waiting official
confirmation for that meantime the
French government saying that several
people allegedly linked to the gunmen
are now in custody do we know anything
more about that yeah Secretary of State
who was interviewed by French media this
morning said that five people were taken
into custody
connected to that gunman he didn't give
any details who these people were what
their relation is to the alleged gunman
but the most interesting part of bit of
information to come out of that
interview is that the Secretary of State
said it wasn't impossible that the
gunman might have left as he called it
the territory which means that he might
be on his way or already in Germany you
have to keep in mind Strasbourg is right
on the border with Germany and this gun
man has a history in Germany he was not
only condemned for crimes here in France
but also in neighboring Germany who is
he max because I mean we are starting to
get some more details some more
specifics about him he's 29 years old
he's very well known to the authorities
because as I said earlier he was already
condemned in France in Germany served
some prison time but not for deeds
related to terrorism criminal acts theft
and in fact that man was supposed to be
taken into custody on Tuesday morning
because of attempted homicide that's the
reason why the police went to take him
into custody he was not at home they
found an assault rifle at his house as
we understand but since they couldn't
take him into custody he was free to you
know to do what he did on Tuesday
evening so the same day here in
Strasbourg he apparently I mean when we
talk about the actual incident he
managed to get inside a security zone
around the Christmas market and max I
know that you you have visited those
Christmas markets you're quite familiar
with the security there how do you think
he might have been able to get through
well the French may the the mayor of
Strasbourg himself was at a loss he said
I don't know how he managed to do that
the controls here were pretty thorough
when we got here on Monday the streets
leading up to the Christmas market were
controlled the cars were some cars were
stopped people were had to get out they
had to show what they had in the trunks
so the authorities were on it and we
know that a couple hundred police
officers were always controlling the
area also soldiers because the military
is allowed to operate in cities in
France but of course you know with a
with the number of visitors in a city
like Strasbourg I would think that it's
impossible to have complete control over
the situation but I'm sure that the
authorities will try to figure out what
exactly happened and how the gunman was
able to smuggle in his rifle and we know
he is still at large at this hour GWS
max Wolfman with the latest from
Strasbourg Thank You max